الصور اوليه وصلتنا من القائم
وهي للضربات التي تم الاعلان عنها ربما
ناخذ تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه الصور او حتى عن
المناطق التي تم استهدافها وفقا لمصادر من
المقاومه فصائل المقاومه الاسلاميه في
العراق حيث تم الاعلان عن قصف مقر قياده
عمليات الانبار للحشد الشعبي غربيه العراق
قبل ذلك تم الاعلان عن قصف مناطق بالقائم
عامر لافي انت في متابعه اذا هذه الضربات
داخل
العراق شرقي العراق نتحدث عن القائم وهذه
صور اوليه تصلنا
للضربات الامريكيه فيها ما هو المتوفر من
معلومات تحديدا ايضا ما قالته فصائل فصائل
المقاومه الاسلاميه في العراق عن هذه
المقرات التي
ضربت نعم محمد ما وصلنا حتى الان وما اكده
لنا مصادر الفصائل العراقيه ومصادر امنيه
ان سته مواقع حتى الان تم استهدافها من
جانب القصف الامريكي في القائم كما ذكرت
ربما اهم المناطق التي قصفت هو مقر
العمليات للحشد الشعبي في محافظه الانبار
في غرب العراق وبالتالي استهداف كبير
المكان الاخر ربما الذي حظي باستهداف داف
كبير يمكن القول بان منطقه العكاشات هناك
على ما فهمنا مخازن اسلحه في تلك المنطقه
ومصادر في فصائل المقاومه تحدثت لنا محمد
عن استهدافها باكثر من ثمانيه
صواريخ استهدفت فقط هذه المنطقه ايضا لواء
منطقه او كتيبه المدرعات في اللواء الث
عشر ايضا استهدفت منطقه السكك تم
استهدافها وعلمنا من من مصادر محليه هناك
ان حجم القصف الكبير والاصوات المرتفعه
يعني اثارت الرعب في لدى سكان تلك المنطقه
منطقه السكك مما ادى الى خروج كثير من
الاهالي وافراغ لمنازلهم في تلك المنطقه
مصادر ايضا الحشد ومصادر عفوا فصائل
المقاومه العراقيه تتحدث لنا عن استمرار
عمليه القصف وعن استعدادهم لهذه المواجهه
وعن اخلاء الكثير من المواقع في تلك
المطقه لكن واضح ان العمليه لم تنتهي بعد
وواضح ان هناك مناطق ست ستقصف طبعا اللي
علمناه ايضا النقطه الاخرى والمهمه هو ان
كثير من المناطق التي تم قصفها هي مناطق
كان في السابق قد استخدمت
لاطلاق المسيرات العراقيه التي استهدفت
القواعد الامريكيه سواء في العراق او في
سوريا وتعلم ويعلم الجميع ان عدد كبير من
هذه الاستهدافات تم منذ الحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه البنتاجون في اخر تصريح له
تحدث عن 161 استهدافا اما اي الفصائل
المقاومه العراقيه فتحدث عن استهداف عن
اكثر من 180
استهداف